welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition aka the board
Queen and this video were breaking down
Picard episode eight our mission is to
boldly go where no one has gone before
and give our thoughts on the new entry
as well as what could be happening in
the future after last week's trip down
memory lane this episode turn things up
a notch with some key players getting
big moments throughout the video we'll
be discussing the ins and outs of the
eight episodes plot it's Easter eggs and
what we thought of it as a whole we will
be engaging with heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't had a chance to catch the
show yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel for videos on the show every
week and without the way let's get into
our breakdown of Picard episode 8 okay
so like all episodes have picaud so far
broken pieces opens in the past this is
14 years ago during a ritual of the
shock - oh is leading a ceremony and
she's joined by Nerissa and her auntie
who we learned was the woman that Shoji
encountered on the cube the ritual can
send those that go through it mad but
those that don't will gain an ancient
wisdom from it this is the secret of the
shack - pretty much all of the group go
mad
except for Nerissa who is the only one
that makes it through now one
interesting tidbit here is that we
learned that the Borg cube became broken
because they tried to assimilate her
Auntie whose mind shut down the station
as we learned earlier in the season she
was on the last ship to be assimilated
and thus the cube became the artifact in
Hugh's office Eleanor is hiding out but
he has been tracked by the Romulan
soldiers and they confront him after
sending the Fenris SOS last week seven
of nine shows up and she saves him
Picard in Sochi finally bored la serena
and arias has a moment that that's a bit
like the lady in red one from dodgeball
Raffy confronts Picard over the fact
that Agnes was a mole and for some
reason she suspects og of being one too
but yeah I don't know where she got that
from and honestly I did feel like this
moment was quite poorly handled from
last week the Serb made it seem like due
to Rafi being suspected of being the
mole that Ria's may end up trying to
kill her he had a thing going on with
Agnes and never learned the truth from
her
so it did seem like it would add a lot
to this episode
however the tension is stripped away
immediately that plot thread is dropped
and completely glossed over I found this
really disappointing as there's no real
conflict from it and I was expecting a
lot more after asserting that they think
Agnes killed Bruce Maddox the park comes
to a standstill a bit with Picard and
Coe trying to learn what's going on
later in the episode Picard does
confront Agnes over it and quickly he
discovers that she did kill Maddox and
that she betrayed them as theorised
Agnes did this because she learned the
secret of the shack - and this sent her
completely over the edge Agnes has
witnessed the apocalypse and she brought
retribution to Maddox for his melding of
synth in organic she's been through hell
and knows that the destroyer is coming
and it will end all life yikes
Agnes does change her mind though pretty
quickly upon meeting shoji and is to
show that perhaps there is hope for
those that have been brainwashed by the
media or or by political figures you
know just just a bit of social
commentary there Rafi goes about the
ship trying to find out how a unique
star system was formed but her running
into different Holograms or with
different accents felt like a bit of a
sketch show to me again that she was
getting closer to uncovering the truth
behind the Romulan conspiracy but the
tone of it felt a bit out of place with
the show for me through the Holograms we
learn why Rios got all misty-eyed before
seeing so gee they dragged their heels
in order to reveal it but we do learn
that Rios's prior captain killed himself
which sent him into a breakdown during a
mission captain Vandermeer and rios
beamed aboard an ambassador and his
daughter Jana who we learned look like
Shoji they were since and has since were
banned the order was given by Commodore
oh who put out a black flag directive to
kill them the captain shot them both
without question in cold blood and this
caused Rios to have a big argument with
the character which led to the captain
putting a phaser in his mouth
Picaro also goes face-to-face with
Clancy and tries to secure a squadron in
one of the funniest scenes thus for
Clancy once more gets some of the most
unintentionally hilarious lines in the
season and watching her tell Picard to
shut the F up killed me she's the she
the best she's the best now what I
really liked about this episode is that
sodium picard really build their
relationship throughout the entry she's
tackling with the dilemma over whether
she's really who she thinks she is
or if she's just programming everything
inside of her her memories and a past
are all secondhand information that have
been given to her but Picard states that
she has a true past that lies with data
Picard informs her of her father and you
really get the warmth that John Luke
felt towards the character this
relationship has really been the driving
force of the entire season and it's nice
to be reminded of that in these moments
there's a touch of survivor's guilty air
and Picard describes himself through
data's eyes almost selling himself short
in some ways Picard admits that he loved
data in his own way and because of his
description so Qi summarizes that he
loved him too aboard the Borg cube 7m9
and Eleanor go to the bull Queens cell
or think that's what it is
7:09 says it's now about Hugh said it
was and as we know the Borg don't really
have bedrooms so this seems more in line
with the continuity of the shows prior
entries whilst Nerissa attempts to hunt
the two down seven regenerates the cube
and it begins to rebuild itself they
argue over whether to assimilate the
Borg once more and it's definitely one
of the most interesting aspects of the
episode seven ends up fusing with the
cube and becoming a new Borg Queen
seeing her say we are Borg is another
highlight of the season to me and she
activates the collective however Nerissa
has a trick of a sleeve and she ejects
them all into space it really elevates
the villain and I'm glad that she's
taken the focus over narak and she
really feels like the true big bad that
the season needs
I felt mega sorry for the Borg yet again
and it's not difficult to have sad eyes
watching them flow off into the great
beyond now in the first episode during
Picard stream data revealed that he had
five queens this was an impossible hand
but I believe that it actually has a lot
of bearing on the show this fall it is
possible that there have actually been
five people in the season that could
take up the role of the Borg Queen and
this seems to be gaining a lot more
weight the further we get into the
season these aren't really in
chronological order but the first Queen
was dodge the second Queen so G the
third jana and the fourth seven this
means that there will be one more that
will fit the role if the theory is true
and I think that we may learn who this
is in the next two episodes
it could be Agnes Raffy or well even
IRISA and it will
be interesting to see how this develops
or if I'm just reaching the finale of
the episode centered around ERISA being
grabbed by the Borg and then transported
out there but it is possible that she
could end up being assimilated in some
way most of the plot points come to a
head on a Serena and we learn the truth
behind the mystery in this season Rafi
has discovered that thousands of years
ago the Romulans placed a warning that
would show of since are created then
they will destroy all life in the
universe they stated there was a
threshold for since evolving and if this
line was crossed then something terrible
would come the Romulans formed the jack
vash whose mission was to terminate all
synthetic life after the creation of
sins that rivaled and even surpassed
humans
the Romulans sent in how to infiltrate
Starfleet to ensign tagged life-forms no
matter the cost
this of course led to the false flag
attack on Mars that forced the
Federation to ban all synths this caused
Maddox to flee to an unknown world to
carry out his work of melding synth and
organic and Gianna came from this planet
and was picked up by the ship that ríos
was aboard this planet is where the
synth nest is located and the group
decide to head there in order to warn
them back aboard the cube we see Nerissa
and the Romulans evacuate because of the
Borg uprising and seven drops control
over the cube the episode ends with la
serena heading out to the nest and
picard reminisces over how much he loved
the silence of space and he and rios
discussed their shared history they come
to the conclusion that Vandermeer must
have known that Gianna was synthetic and
thus he was able to carry out the orders
to kill her however it wasn't his fault
it was Starfleet's that brainwashed him
they let fear and their prejudice stop
them from being open and welcoming to
other life-forms and I think that the
show is trying to comment on how the
world views immigration and people from
different nationalities it says that
just because things have happened in the
past to cause this fear that it doesn't
mean we should go into the future
crippled by this thought process it's a
deep conversation that I wish went on
longer
however as Shoji arrives in NZ with them
arriving at the jump point that will
hurtle them towards their destination
her compass which was broken last week
now points directly north showing that
she has finally found her way just when
it seems that they're safe narak ship
appears and follows them which ends the
episode as for next week it looks like
they're travelling across the universe
incredible speed and that they will be
crash landing on the planet it's
difficult to tell exactly what could
happen as the preview is so short but it
looks like Sochi is going home even if
there's a travel ban Oh topical topical
here on the channel anyway though I feel
like this was one of the weaker episodes
in terms of certain aspects such as the
Raffi scenes actually feel like it had
some of the best moments in the season
thus far with just two episodes left I'm
really excited to see where things could
go and hopefully we'll get some theories
confirmed next week now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on Picard so
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up and if you've missed any of
our breakdown so far then they're gonna
be linked in a playlist at the end if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank-you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
Definition YT or click the discord link
in the description below every month we
give away free movies to people or
subscribe to the channel and this month
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning the Infinity Saga box
set is leave a comment and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of March so best of
luck that every only takes part this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you